according to a new study Media Research
Center guess what 90% of the coverage on
the three big networks ABC NBC CBS from
September to November about president
Trump well 90% negative and despite all
of that the president continues to stay
focused he's working hard he's pushing
his agenda through the economy is still
soaring we look much better on the world
stage and today he made his argument in
support of the GOP tax plan finished
many Americans will be getting money
back thank God
joining us now with reaction counselors
are the president Kelly and Conway
you know the president I one time I
think he saw the show cuz you made fun
of me privately and I was doing all the
trumps accomplishments
ding-ding-ding-ding-ding I know the
media doesn't cover that all the
regulations he got done this is now a
corporate tax cut that's massive
middle-class tax cut or patreon this is
a big deal and energy independence
millions of jobs will be created on an
already growing and recovering economy
today was truly one of the most exciting
days since we've been there this year
and you can see it you can feel the
president was very excited to host five
families Sean all of whom accepted his
invitation to go up to the podium in
front of live TV cameras and tell their
stories unscripted they've thought long
and hard about what they would do with
extra money in their pockets there's
been like a one-way ticket for
everybody's money going from their
wallet to Washington and this president
is stopping that he's stopping the
bleeding and you heard these families
say some would invest it in their
children's education some are going to
invest into home renovations another
family from Washington state said they
would give it to folks who were in need
chair gives some charitable
contributions in their community but the
point is the expectation the
anticipation alone of reducing that
corporate rate making us more
competitive bringing those jobs back
from overseas a centerpiece of president
Trump's economic pledge to this nation
just the anticipation of it has meant
17-year high in consumer confidence
yesterday we saw and if I be in other
small business groups like the small
business entrepreneurship council
they're all coming out with their
measurements they've never seen anything
like it
so this were on the verge of passing
historic taxi form the presence of
something else important today he said
that people would start seeing the
difference in their paychecks in
February when you fight our taxes by
April 15th next year you you will have
seen the difference in your paychecks he
is the paycheck president let me ask you
Kellyanne you saw what happened with
Rosenstein today you've heard me lay out
the whole narrative which struck and his
girlfriend Lisa page you got Andrew
Weissman you got all the Democratic
donors you got the exoneration before
the investigation
the dossier then you got Bruce or Bruce
ORS wife Fusion GPS Hillary bought paid
for Russian propaganda to influence the
election you put all this together and
you look at where we are where are you
on all of this because I know where I am
this isn't the most corrupt I've ever
seen things at the top the deep state is
alive and well and they've been working
overtime to hurt this president day in
and day out the president has made very
clear many times Sean that he has a
great deal of faith in the rank and file
at the FBI and intelligence agencies and
many of the hard-working men and women
in his government at the same time we
always want investigations to be
independent to be fair to be transparent
and accountable and Americans have a
right to feel disturbed by what they see
not what's being spun to them but what
they see in text exchanges what they see
in terms of people's political
motivations
I'm predilections so I'm glad I'm glad
the information evidence is getting out
there but from my perspective in the
White House it shows you the split
screen of what's going on you see all of
that that this this hovering
investigation about 2016 and we're back
to the Clinton campaign and all this
again we just can't get rid of them
somehow someway I'd love to but you see
the split screen you have the president
Donald Trump standing there today on the
verge of tax relief and by the way he
also is doing something else tomorrow
he's going to be talking about massive
deregulation there's an op-ed right
he's already proud I mean out in the
Wall Street Journal that's huge
but he's noticing tomorrow so people
understand he promised
to to regulations out for every new one
in he's way ahead he and his agencies
are way ahead of that saving you
billions of dollars as taxpayers
Kellyanne always good to see you and by
the way I don't see him
have a Merry Christmas you can say Merry
Christmas again the president says all
right Merry Christmas Merry Christmas
and Happy Hanukkah and Happy Hanukkah -
amen